hello there reject nation it's Greg Alba
today I'm gonna check out the trailer
for Black Knight who died named Black
Lightning the power struggles trailer
I'm excited for this show man you know
I'm still a tad bit behind on arrow and
flash I'm on the current season a few
episodes behind I know right now when
this show comes out it's not gonna be
immediately linked to the arrow verse
but it sounds like that there a me to
eventually have it linked to the arrow
but it's on the CW it would just make
sense
and plus the things I know about Black
Lightning I feel like would be great
crossover with the flash especially the
flash if he does have the lightning
speed power I mean that would just be
cool to see in the same show really
quick before I go into this trailer I
wanted to say thank you to everyone who
download the Stardust app and followed
us because we just passed three thousand
followers we've been aiming to get to 3k
for a while now on the journey to four
thousand followers we really love using
this app they're easily the best sponsor
we've ever worked with the app allows
you to do 30-second reviews or reactions
for any film TV show or trailer so you
can get an early access to our opinions
we make post about movies and shows that
we haven't exactly covered on the
YouTube channel and plus there's a lot
of your favorite youtubers use you know
Tyrone just signed up for it actually
everyone knows Tyrone Magnus don't
follow Tyrone first download our link
and follow us first can't have him be
bigger than us in every area especially
his Black Lightning you know what I mean
cuz he's probably got a bigger penis
watch this
one hundreds man who James remar Zinn
this show
nice yeah I'm tuning in
I already did Black Lightning I already
did subscribe that's how I know about
this trailer from what I can remember of
what I've read about Black Lightning and
what I read about this show they want to
make it less villain of the week and
less procedural and make it more one of
those shows that has a strong storyline
that you have to consistently follow for
every single episode because they want
to really take the time to explore the
villains I think the guy with the beer
was the character named Tobias whale and
main villain of the show who's one of
the leaders or is the leader of the 100
gang what I'm really hoping that the
show does is give us that gritty on the
streets vibe you know I feel like shows
such as arrow on the CW can push its
boundaries in terms of the violence the
tone and vibe while it can be pretty
dark it still has sort of this cheesy
vibe about it to keep it a little bit
light-hearted for the DC CW shows even
though it's the darkest one I've seen on
the CW the show's gonna be dealing with
gangsters and the slums the ghetto and I
really hope it has a strong sense of
that world that has a strong sense of
that darkness because the show supposed
to start off with Jefferson as this guy
who was formerly Black Lightning and
what's supposed to happen he's supposed
to see how bad everything's gotten
around him and that he has a calling to
become the vigilante again of Black
Lightning so I'm really hoping that they
set up the villain well they set up the
ruthlessness of this world well now when
Black Lightning becomes Black Lightning
again we're able to really feel that
sense of yeah he's back
even though this is the first show with
him I feel like this show has an
opportunity to build up Black Lightning
build up the hero build up the legend
that way when he does come back we're
excited to see him and I'm hoping that
when he does become Black Lightning that
it isn't just easy-peasy for him like
and the trailers just makes it look like
he's kicking ass like nobody's business
I want him to have the struggles of
getting his feet wet again getting back
into this territory of fighting crime
and
other aspects I heard about black
lightning that I haven't really heard
them comments about on the show is that
his family knows that he's black
lightning and that his family is
supportive and that's very opposite of a
lot of superhero movies and shows where
they usually have to keep their identity
secret from those who are closest to
them but if the show can start off on
grounds where the family is very
supportive we're when he is being a
father when he's just being a family man
that that family drama is also just as
effective as the superhero drama and
then in turn it raises both stakes I
feel like with everything I've heard
about black lighting this show has the
potential to do it the way it's shot
feels more gritty now the first episode
just really has to establish a tone
because right now Black Lightning looks
badass
it looks gritty I just hope that it has
a sick tone that feels darker and stands
out from the arrow versus really feeling
like it's its own thing and that it
would be cool if they do crossover
eventually I feel like they probably
will I just really want it to feel like
it's its own thing in the beginning so
when it does crossover it does feel more
special in the end see how that works at
least keep a lookout for my star dust
review on it you can subscribe to the
reel rejects click that notification
bell download and follow us at the start
us up at the real rejects and become a
patron oject today it's like a second
youtube channel over there posting
plenty of exclusive vids on the pot
wrong